and thank you all once again for
clicking on my face maybe the red
background caught your eye maybe you're
a long time watcher and subscriber in
any case in either case i love you and
first i want to thank the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by nordvpn because though we are
cruising through life on this pale blue
dot we are doing so living our lives
through the digital railways of the
internet so it's more important than
ever to protect you and your information
thus i bring this to you nordvpn's a vpn
service that protects you and your
information from the ever prying eyes
and the spies of the internet but it
doesn't stop there we're all movie buffs
and entertainment buffs nordvpn allows
you to watch your favorite movies and
shows even if you're abroad change your
virtual location with one click you can
choose between over 5 100 servers in 60
countries you gotta love those options
so click the link below go to
nordvpn.com
john's get yourself a two-year
subscription plus one additional month
with a huge discount and with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee it's
risk-free you know i love that peace of
mind and thank you once again to nordvpn
for sponsoring this video i do
appreciate it and now it dawns on me
i've never done a video on the original
terminator movie why have i not done
that
so the original terminator james
cameron's terminator was released in
1984 story goes james cameron had a
fever dream in which he imagined a
skeleton rising from fire fever dream
can we get james cameron on the joe
rogan podcast that joe rogan can pull
out of him whether or not it was really
a fever dream or a fever dream point is
it's proof that fever dreams make for
some pretty epic art now terminator 1 is
a different kind of movie than
terminator 2 when i was younger i was i
was like yeah terminator 1 and 2. it's
easy to compare i felt like terminator 2
was everything terminator 1 was but i
had more but it's not as i've aged it's
very apples to oranges terminator 2 is
one of the greatest sci-fi action films
of all time terminator 1 is one of the
greatest sci-fi horror films of all time
the story of terminator in case you
don't know is in the future well the
past now i guess august 29 1997 there
was this nuclear war this nuclear
holocaust that the humans that survived
called judgment day the machines did
that to wipe out a lot of humanity the
surviving humans of that future which is
kind of the past at this point there's
only a few more years for us until all
of the future of terminator 1 and 2 is
now in the past she feel old too because
i really do point is an apocalyptic
feature of humans versus machines the
machine sent back a terminator a machine
played by arnold schwarzenegger to kill
the mother of the leader of the
resistance sarah connor so the human
sent back a lone soldier named kyle
reese to protect her which means you
don't have terminator vs terminator
combat like you have in terminator 2
judgement day and that really shows how
james cameron terminator movies play up
their strengths you know in terminator 2
you have terminator versus terminator
yeah sure john connor and sarah connor
are still fleshy you know they're gonna
die in like one hit from the t-1000 but
for the most part you can have the
terminator and t-1000 duke it out you
know they have the shield they have
their tank as long as john connor and
sarah connor have the terminator their
tank the tank can take the hits from the
dps enemy terminator 1 feels completely
different from that you have kyle reese
and sarah connor it's kind of like a
healer and a rogue going up against this
huge tank dps boss level red you've ever
been in a raid you understand they're
not equipped and that's where james
cameron plays this up terminator 1 plays
out like a horror movie it's cyborg
jason voorhees before there was cyborg
jason voorhees you put those keyboards
down i'm not comparing the terminator
with jason x i'm just saying i have to
clarify because i said cyborg jason
voorhees it's the internet it's youtube
you understand you get it terminator in
terminator 1 is so imposing so scary
there's a physicality to him in
terminator 1. he's so much bigger than
he was in terminator 2. i mean
terminator 2 arnold schwarzenegger was
no joke there i mean it's not like i'd
go pick a fight with the guy he's still
enormous in crazy physical shape but in
terminator 1 he was beyond human and for
the first block the first act of this
movie it plays up tensions movie plays
up tension amazingly well said akana yes
she starts killing the sarah connors in
the phone book
funny enough the terminator kills sarah
connor's roommate thinking she's sarah
connor if sarah connor hadn't phoned
home
terminator was just gone away he thought
the job was done dominated
i guess i'll
start the family
there's a smart thing to do i feel so
bad about it now between the
terminator's physical presence in the
movie and that come to jesus monologue
that kyle reese gives sarah connor where
it's like this thing will not stop ever
until you're dead you really feel the
lack of hope that these characters have
they never go on the offense they're
always running defense they're always
running from the terminator who always
ends up finding them it's not a movie of
hope terminator 2 actually ends with
that message of hope terminator 1 is not
a movie of hope it's a movie of
impending doom and you're just delaying
the inevitable there is that wiring in
our brain that transcends hope and that
is the will to survive and terminator to
me is all about that even on the
machine's perspective like yeah we wiped
out humanity because we just wanted to
survive everyone wants to survive it's a
thing that everyone understands to their
core arnold in terminator 1
is much more machine like than he is in
terminator 2. that scene he's in the car
and he's driving and he's constantly
scanning like this you can just tell
he's like a cylon you know the scanner
is always on which i get terminator 2
it's it's a machine becoming more human
or at least the best version of humanity
when kyle reese says he can't be
bargained with or reasoned with
you understand that you see that in the
terminator's action there is no talking
to this thing and there's nothing i can
add to the conversation of that police
station massacre that terminator does
it's just legit cinematic glory really
is a great scene and the musical score
the musical score is top not just like
that
cyber musical score that movies and
games now try to go back to but you know
germinator was just kind of like yeah
it's what we have it's the technology of
the time and we're making that
synthesized music and it works for the
movie the musical score is great not to
mention the theme which is iconic
all-time
theme in movies ever but what is
humanity if you don't have a couple of
very human and relatable characters to
lash onto first of all linda hamilton as
sarah connor if you ever have that that
conversation of strongest female heroes
in a movie ellen ripley and sarah connor
are at the top too and as much as sarah
connor being the badass is very much
terminator 2 this is the genesis of that
kyle reese and sarah connor are very
relatable characters you know kyle
reeves isn't some beefcake soldier he's
not built like jai courtney or anything
he just seems like this average everyday
guy who happened to grow up in a time
where there's a war between humans and
machines yes ptsd is constantly plagued
with nightmares sarah connor's a
waitress down on her luck they just
they're not the ideal people to go up
against a terminator they're not the
ideal people to save the future but it's
the great collateral said even the
smallest person can change the course of
the future that's what they embody
it's another reason i love lord of the
rings point is heroes aren't born
they're made and they're the ones who
have to step up in this situation and
they do an impossible scenario of the
impossible cinematic scenarios this is
this is one of them just makes them very
relatable characters it's easy for the
audience to project themselves into the
movie and be like hey i'm here with you
because i wouldn't stand a chance either
another thing i caught it's like
something i catch every time and every
time i see it i'm like that's cool it's
when the guy knocks on the door and
arnold's response to him is [ __ ] you
[ __ ] but what the guy asks is you
have a dead cat in there and all the
flies are on arnold's face
because his flesh is rotting he's been
shot a bunch of times he's getting
infections and he smells horrific his
flesh is literally rotting that's so
cool because at that point it changes it
from this cybernetic organism to a cyber
skeleton with rotting flesh coming after
you adding to the horror vibe i also
love the fact that the movie doesn't
show you too much of the terminator any
glimpse of the robotics is like a treat
you know it's a gift that's given to you
the audience and you relish it you see
the robotic tendons he peels his eye out
you see the robotic eye but it doesn't
show you too much until the very end yes
some of the effects are dated the movie
came out in the 80s especially you look
at terminator 2 you're like yeah wow
that's that's a huge leap in technology
but there's something cool about the
terminator it costs about six and a half
million dollars or something like that
it's
the kind of movie that inspires young
filmmakers to make movies the point is
terminator 1 is a masterpiece of a genre
as terminator 2 is terminator 2 sci-fi
action movie terminator 1 sci-fi horror
movie it's a movie of tension suspense
and fear with amazing sci-fi lore in
there because the terminator is
awesome tacular
so i gotta do now in this modern age to
get your awesome taculars i
gotta go back you get your ball off my
lawn you kids all right so the
terminator have you seen it what did you
think about it i hope you've seen it i
mean if you haven't seen it dude watch
it i actually saw terminator 2 before i
saw terminator 1 when i was younger so
that probably aids in the fact that i
felt like well terminator 1 is just kind
of terminator 2 with less stuff which is
why it took me getting older to realize
what terminator 1 actually offered that
terminator 2 did not but the terminator
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you